ah nature this leaf is fuzzy like the
underside of my ballsack good evening
everyone we are out here at the place
that I like to go on these lovely walks
that there's a bunch of children walking
around I said hello to them their
parents told me to get the [ __ ] away
either way I'm gonna kidnap you as a
promise this year I told you guys that
I'll be more inclusive I was gonna
create more content and a big part of
creating this content isn't just about
making these funny videos it's about
showing you guys what's going on in my
life and recently as you guys may know I
purchased the [ __ ] vehicular motor
Sun bulb
basically I like dog [ __ ] and what I'm
saying is when it comes to the vehicular
motors that I buy and the one that I
just purchased it's all about being a
dope fast accessible and basically I
needed to go groomed room so I could get
that V V vagina
flatout right over there is the Honda
Element
is the cause I know some of you guys
were shocked by the sound of the engine
how fierce it was [ __ ] you guys I have
been wanting this car for a very very
long time and a lot of people don't
understand ie Bart you know that buff a
little meathead talking about if you get
the Honda Element nobody's gonna like
you such a [ __ ] ass car well that may
be true but I like it the reason why I
like the Honda Element is because number
one it's very inconspicuous
now the other cars that I have is a
Tesla Model S and a lot of the joints
that I like to eat at or go to it's
[ __ ] ghetto okay it's what I'm
comfortable with
so if I go into this hood with the Tesla
Model S I'm going to get so that was one
of the reasons why I got the Honda
Element because if you rob a Honda
Element basically you're basically a
thief with really low self-esteem now
let's talk about how this trunk opens
it's not that typical SUV type of [ __ ]
it's kind of like a truck bifold
I don't know car terms but I call it by
phone even like the truck where you had
that that that top cover same thing - it
even has like a little tailgating ban
performance let's hop into the front
seat and talk about some of the features
huh shall we now this vehicle high-tech
as it is has a CD player my friend now I
like CD players
I don't play CDs in it but the cool
thing about CD players is that you get
to put your little iPhone slot thing in
the front and it's like you have a GPS
but you really don't because this cars
really old probably the thing that I
like the most about the Honda Element is
how much stuff you can stash in this car
we're talking about cubby space we're
talking about hidden spots we're talking
about glove compartment space the whole
shebang so let's talk about one of the
things that I enjoy the most is this
right here this thing is so cool look at
this give it a pop so much space to put
[ __ ] on a lot of times when you
drive you don't really want to think
about where you want to place things you
just
pop it up and put it right there the
second spot that I like the most is in
the passenger seat check this spot out a
lot of the times your passengers will
have [ __ ] and they try to put it
into your center console I'm like listen
here you [ __ ] [ __ ] bag that's my
space you put it in your [ __ ] cubby
which the Honda Element provides another
cool thing is if your passenger wants to
charge their own [ __ ] guess what they
got their own little flip-flops like
that's pretty flying a bagel right there
so if they try to charge their stupid
ass iPhone on your charger you could
tell them to go [ __ ] themselves let's
talk about some of the secret
compartments now we already told you
about this one right here but check this
out look at me it's for year 2000 and I
smoke weed and I need to hide it I bet
you didn't know about this this is where
I keep the good weed in the condoms
because sometimes when I have sex I like
to sleep on the person these seats right
here by the way are also waterproof so
if you're driving your car and you're
like oh [ __ ] oh no it's getting rumbling
I spilled some water
what oh [ __ ] is not waterproof oh okay I
guess like the other models are water
but cut that [ __ ] out one thing about
this car that I really really dislike is
the amount of disrespect my car's been
getting from all these birds the bird
[ __ ] on this damn car like there's legit
where I live there's like probably about
40 cars that are parked on the street
and for some [ __ ] reason he attacked
my car I don't get it but what's with
the disrespect huh beautiful boxy
exterior is made not to be aerodynamic
so when you drive in high winds it's
supposed to feel like your cards gonna
topple over which actually can't happen
[ __ ] [ __ ] what people may not know
about the Honda Element as well is that
this car is actually a two-door car it's
two-door so I guess technically it's a
sports car you know what I'm saying do
that right there pop this side thing out
and there you go and people have to go
through the back I also took out the
backseat not just for utility purposes
because people are like yo you have a
car let's all just carpool in your
sunlight no it's two seats you [ __ ]
[ __ ] go drive yourself by VTech 2.4
the hoax cup that's German for really
really fast over here we have this thing
this is a girl's skirt as she's peeing
on the bottom I don't know why they have
this hieroglyph here yeah man that's
that's the uh yeah that's the ride
that's the Honda Element um are you
surprised about how dope it is probably
are you gonna get one yourself you
probably can because this is serenity
it's hard to find a Honda Element in
this condition and this beauty this car
actually only has about like eighty
three thousand miles for this vehicle
which was really really really hard to
find so I don't plan on selling this any
time soon if I have to that I will but
it's it's my [ __ ] man I actually I
really do like this car the only time it
did fail me is when I was going camping
and then there was like a slight breeze
and then I almost died because it almost
threw me off a cliff but that the car is
really faithful none of you bought my
[ __ ] and that's why I closed down and
now I'm a giraffe and somebody shot me
out of Africa's wild please oh [ __ ]
[Music]
but I'm driving this car and I got the
windows now sometimes I can hear the
wind [ __ ] you say that
[Music]